[Music]
white
allergies white white allergies this one
sort of pains me a little bit because
Matthew MCC first of I think he's an
absolutely spectacular actor
Interstellar is an incredible movie he
was unbelievable in Wolf of Wall Street
in um what was the pop movie uh the pop
movie from 30 years
ago uh not well Dallas Buyers Club he
was great enough but I'm talking about
the the high school one in Dallas uh in
Texas what the come on guys somebody
does anyone have a computer in this room
does
anyone with the weed yeah the the girls
keep getting younger the great thing
about high school girls is I keep
getting older and they keep getting
younger whatever or they stay the same
age anyone no not Failure to Launch
people we killing valuable time here
what was the movie and Dazed and
Confused thank you Jesus all right
anyway generally speaking I like the guy
he's had conversations with Jordan
Peterson he gets it on so much stuff but
maybe this is just part of being
Hollywood being in the Hollywood Machine
when you're in the Hollywood Machine and
you are white and you are a man no no
matter how much good work you've done
whether you're married to a apparently
non-white woman no matter where where
you grew up and what you must bow to the
altar of racial politics check out this
video this is really
disappointing I heard this term the
other day and I've never heard it before
and I went what and talked to this
person he explained it to
me white
allergies white white allergies that
that by where we were raised and how we
were raised in our history uh growing up
there's certain just imported obvious
ways that we're Prejudice in ways that
that that that we don't even understand
we got white allergies and may not even
know it and
so I was sitting there you know looking
at my own life and I sit there and I go
all right tell me mhm Long View High
School was over 50% black I applied to
Grambling I was the first white to ever
work at Catfish Station in all Blues
black blues bar on Sixth Street I am
married to a non-white immigrant I have
black friends all through my life and
still Doh but what prejudices may I have
via white allergies that I may
not it's so incredible these struggle
sessions he spends the entire time I'm
not a racist my wife's not I got black
friends I worked at a catfish place but
but I still have white allergies I I
mean it's also the phrase white
allergies it's so idiotic although I
will say it's hard to picture a black
guy using flones don't you think I feel
like white people only use flones but
that's not because of white allergies
there's just something else going on
there with flones I don't know anyway
it's all so stupid this struggle section
session like dude you you're basically
saying hey I've lived my life to the
best of my ability but what what can I
do to bow to you black man and imagine
if if white people started saying black
people have black allergies right like
think how absolutely insane it
is